bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france quel est l'objet des négociations
actuelles entre benny gantz et benyamin
nétanyahou est ce que selon vous un
accord est possible au final bien sûr
qu'un accord est possible
toujours possible on est dans un pays
qui est extrêmement démocratique donc on
est bien sûr dans un dans un moment un
peu critique bien entendu puisque vous
avez trois fois qu'on représente que les
hypothèses se présentent aux urnes mais
je pense qu'effectivement il ya une
possibilité pour une raison très simple
c'est que on peut pas aller vers une
quatrième élection c'est pas possible
surtout dans ce contexte sécuritaire
plutôt son contexte sanitaire qui fait
que le pays est vraiment dans dans la
panade comme tous beaucoup d'autres pays
du monde donc on ne peut pas donc il va
forcément y avoir on espère dans les
quelques heures qui viennent on va
trouver un accord et on va avoir un
gouvernement qui va être plutôt un
gouvernement d'union nationale comme on
l'appelle ici qu'est ce qui bloque
aujourd'hui entre les deux parties alors
ce qui bloque c'est en fait si vous
connaissez un petit peu la politique
israélienne
vous avez donc 120 députés il faut 61
pour avoir la majorité une coalition de
61 61 membres
cette coalition n'arrive pas à y arriver
c'est ça c'est ça le problème est
maintenant qu'on y arriver en prenant
effectivement les la partie de blanc
bleu donc hersen les israël donc était
le le parti de benny ganz
on l'aura en la ralliant effectivement
au premier ministre on ouvre normalement
une majorité de 64 à 68 députés possible
et donc on pourrait former un
gouvernement
le problème c'est que pour pouvoir
arriver à ça il faut faire ce qu'on
appelle une rotation c'est à dire on
permettre à bien me d'athéna ou de
diriger le pays pendant encore un an et
demi après donner la place à benny gantz
le problème c'est que après prendra la
tête du gouvernement
ce qui va se passer c'est que il va
nommer dans la même temps en même temps
le premier ministre actuel nominés mais
dagnoko premier ministre par intérim le
belge devenir pour l'éviter par intérim
donc
un problème juridico politique où on
fait un accord bipartite entre béni
compte et ministre actuel ne n'est pas
sûr de pouvoir continuer voilà en fait
tout le problème c'est pour ça ça
achoppe effectivement dans le fait ou
binyamin netanyahou on n'est pas sûr que
la cour suprême devra ce mail est encore
une fois de cet accord qui sera un
accord entre deux parties et il empêche
en fait de devenir premier ministre par
intérim
voilà qui nous problème est là comment
elle est gérée dans ce contexte
politique la crise sanitaire actuelle
est ce qu'il ya des répercussions de
cette instabilité politique sur la
gestion de la crise du corps d'un viol
écoutez vous savez le peuple d'israël et
le pays d'israël
donc on est un peuple qui sommes très
résilient donc on a très très vite pris
en compte le problème du coronavirus
malgré les problèmes politiques et il ya
quelque chose qui est fondamental c'est
la vie des concitoyens la vie des
citoyens israéliens passent au dessus
tout et très rapidement dès qu' il ya un
problème sécuritaire est donc là c'est
un problème de de sécurité de la vie
donc sanitaires il n'y a absolument
aucune de percussions le premier
ministre est en place il prend les
bonnes mesures
il a toute la pléiade et les instances
et politiques sécuritaires sanitaires et
cetera auprès de lui autour de lui ils
ont pris les décisions les premiers au
nom ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui grâce à
dieu on est un pays où tous les sondages
et tous les articles le disent on est un
des premiers pays protégés par rapport
aux coronavirus et on commence comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure au début
de ce reportage à ceux des confiné
puisque aujourd'hui des mesures de ce
qu'on appelle des à calotte en otage
c'est à dire de ralentissement plutôt de
d'allègement de ces mesures de
confinement sont sont en cours de son
prix en ce moment
les heurts qui qui sont là quoi et alors
d'armes vraiment très rapidement parce
que le temps nous manque à quelle forme
va prendre ce déconfinement qui commence
tout juste
bah écoutez il ya beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup de solutions mais celui qui
pose le plus de problème c'est
effectivement les le problème de
l'éducation et de la rentrée des élèves
de leur rentrée des élèves en cours mais
pour l'instant ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est que on est en train au fur
et à mesure de libérer certaines
professions qui vont elles avoir le
droit de se dé confinés comme des
opticiens comme certains certains
produits qui sont pas forcément des
produits de première nécessité et au fur
et à mesure toute la population va
rentrer en déconfite marche mais encore
une fois ça ce n'est pas l'avis de tous
les gens du gouvernement il ya des gens
qui sont absolument contre et qui ont
peur de ceux des compliments qui ont
peur que tant donné qu'on ne connaît pas
ce virus qui ont peur qu'on revienne en
confinement si les choses se passent mal
quand on va commencer à les confiner
voilà si beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps
de répondre à nos questions msika je
rappelle que vous êtes analyste
politique